a low reject nation it's John here it's
January again you know what that means
means it's time for another horror movie
Oh hold on a second I'm viewing this in
the dark so that the spirits can join oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] that was bad any under turn
the lights up
city it's the last key the fourth
installment in the insidious franchise a
little strange that it's coming out and
now as it was originally supposed to
come out last year during the Halloween
season then it got pushed back I think
so that they could put out happy
deathday instead which makes sense and
for me it's nice to have something to
look forward to this style in January
start off the year with something I love
but before I hop into my thoughts on the
new movie I wanted to give a quick shout
out to our video sponsors Stardust
you've heard about them you know their
name go check us out over there it's a
great app that basically allows you to
make 30-second reviews first impressions
etc for any film TV show or trailer
that's out there it's pretty fun and
it's a great way to see what everybody's
thinking see what the real people are
thinking if you don't want to just check
out Rotten Tomatoes it's like a capsule
review but from everybody and a lot of
your favorite youtubers are on there so
go check that out follow us first as
well make sure to do that so they know
we sent you actually here I'm I'll play
right now my review for the first three
insidious films from Stardust just so
you guys can get a sense for how I feel
about you know these movies I remember
when I first saw insidious mana I really
loved this movie and especially coming
in as a Soffen see Leigh Whannell and
James Wan do something that's completely
the opposite completely unreliable at
house movie tropes and bothers to make
better choices with them I think is
great the cast is awesome the music is
really wacky and shrill and foreboding
and it's got some good imagination
while it is a love letter to poltergeist
I think it does bring its own funhouse
vibe and it's really intense insidious
chapter 2 not as tight as the first
movie I will give you in some might
argue that it's not entirely essential
however I do think that again James Wan
Leigh Whannell were not lazy about this
they really tied it into the family and
really bothered to wrap up their story
and I liked that they they tribute they
they love letter a different vibe
entirely going for more like The Shining
and stuff like that then poltergeist
with this one and yeah it does go even
crazier with its funhouse vibe but I
think that works it's fun this one's
Laban elves directorial debut and while
it's not without its flaws I do think he
has a pretty good grip on the horror
elements the scares and whatnot and I
like that this movie makes concerted
effort to focus on and to really walk
around in the traumas and the struggles
of the leads especially Quinn the young
woman who's the focus of this story the
focus of the haunting and her loss of
her mother Lin Shaye is terrific as
always tuck her in specs are a lot of
fun it's got all the insidious earmarks
but with its own flair and overall I
think it's pretty good yep so those are
my thoughts overall you can tell I
generally I'm a fan of insidious I've
enjoyed pretty much all the movies for
different reasons not that I think they
haven't you know had flaws along the way
I think the first one is definitely the
most solid and going into this fourth
one I wasn't exactly sure what to expect
I think I only end up seeing the one
trailer that we did the reaction to no
sort of surprised that they moved it to
January I think they were gearing up for
a Halloween time a fall release of some
kind of and I thought one of two things
at that moment I thought on the one hand
Blum House has sort of done really well
lately in the first part of the year you
know split came out in January get out
came out in February it seems like maybe
they're carving out our niche and for
people like me that's a nice thing to be
able to look forward to a horror movie
at the start of the year especially
something of caliber in any capacity but
on the other hand it also kind of made
me worried just because this is one of
their flagship franchises I'm curious as
to why they would bump it there and
ultimately with all that I went in sort
of cold cuz I'd forgotten it was coming
out until shouts out to Wendy Lee over
at the movie couple and Collider she hit
me up and that reminded me and then I
got excited so basically the main gist
of this movie is focused in on Elyse now
and she gets another call from
someone who needs help with a haunting
but this time it's not just any old
haunted house it is her childhood home
in five keys New Mexico so Elise
literally has to go back and confront
the demons of her past in order to help
out with this situation this is also
another prequel it takes place before
the events of the original insidious if
you've seen that movie the reasons why
are pretty obvious but one of the first
things that struck me about this movie
when I appreciated the most about this
movie is that in moving forward they've
really taken the personal elements of
this franchise and dialed them up
because early on in this movie makes it
clear that this is mostly about Elise
even the malevolent forces she's called
to deal with are are intrinsically tied
to her past in a way that doesn't feel
or at least to me didn't feel cheesy the
way it so often does the prologue of
this movie is surprisingly raw and
natural that's the first impression the
movie makes on you is that this is gonna
be about Elise and this is gonna deal
with the traumas and struggles of her
past growing up
you see she grew up in a really
dysfunctional family and her gift was
not viewed that way by everybody and so
much of the action of this movie
directly involves her confronting and
dealing with her own demons as well as
the physical demons on-screen so that's
a cool thing like right off the bat I
feel like this movies doing some work
that your average haunted house movie
might not do it and that's been in the
DNA of insidious from the get-go like
it's always partly about challenging the
tropes of these movies and in some ways
I think in adjusting the themes and the
focus on certain elements they've
managed to adapt into oddly subtly build
a franchise out of this and I love that
it's Lin Shay's franchise at least at
this moment I mean out of that seed
planted in the first movie when she
comes in partway through she's the cool
intriguing supporting character and now
she is the heart and soul of this
franchise and I mean Lin Shaye is like
in her 70s but she kills it in this
movie I just think it's so cool that she
gets to lead this and she does a
terrific job and that's also where Adam
rabbit tail comes in the director they
got to do this also did a movie called
the taking of Deborah Logan which is
sort of a twist on found footage but
that takes its supernatural elements
from a very real situation which is you
know it's exploring that with a horror
sort of metaphor this movie does
something similar with at least both in
the fact that they focus on developing
that character and they focus in on her
past and some of the tough - soon as she
made growing up but they also focus
sit on her with the camera they choose a
lot of long lenses there's a shallow
focus you really get to focus on Elise's
face or her body language it's
surprisingly intimate in that way which
makes this a little more of a film than
I was expecting truly like the center of
this movie is Elise and I think that's a
really cool thing for them to do with
this it makes the most sense for a
franchise she's gonna be involved with a
revolving door of spooky experiences
makes sense tuck her in specs are also
back for this movie I enjoy them I know
some people don't and I get why the
comedy isn't always a hundred percent
but I do think that their dynamic as a
trio is oddly perfect because they're
always off in their own world and they
really are man children and she feels
like their mom and even their story gets
updated a little bit in this new sequel
every time they show up they're a little
bit different their gadgets and stuff
contribute to the style of the movie
there are some really cool audio
passages where the sound quality is
different there's some cool visual
passages that are kind of like found
footage in some ways there's a lot of
use of color and cool lighting i think
adam Robicheaux really brought a lot to
the table with this and I think Leigh
Whannell script too cuz he's written all
these movies does a good job of again
not being lazy exploring some of the
crucial characters and also bringing in
some cool new ones and I guess the only
big thing I would complain about with
this movie is that there are times when
it starts to feel choppy where certain
scenes will feel more written or more
richly written than other scenes well
there are some moments that just feel
like whoo we got to move the plot along
or all we got to remind people of the
important information we learned so I
wish some of those had either been more
fleshed out or maybe they've given us a
little more credit for paying attention
each of these movies has its own twists
and turns and there are a lot of
different genres they're drawing from
and there are times during this movie
where plot developments will hit and at
least for me would be kind of jarring
and that's not entirely to the movies
detriment because by the end I feel like
it does pay off and at least attempt to
justify everything that it brings up but
at the same time there are moments that
hit you're like whoa whoa whoa what
happened hold on I'm missing new details
because I'm trying to swallow that last
foot and these movies have always
flirted with that line I feel like
that's part of the happy byproduct of
the continent how its approach is that
they are free to get a little zany
sometimes and for me I feel like that's
just a matter of
where yours a Nena scale is because like
moments in the third movies sort of
pushed me for that but this one didn't
do it as much and I appreciated that
again they've built this out into a
franchise and I think one of the
smartest things they've done with that
is really focus in on the family aspect
and it's funny the James one also has
the conjuring because both of these
franchises rest the spookier elements
and the ghost story stuff on top of the
emotional lives of their characters to
some extent you know they make a
concerted effort towards that into
making the human stories at least
resonant and even the third insidious
movie marked I thought a more direct
shift toward making that a focus of
these like you really get to know Quinn
in that movie you get to know her life
and her struggles and the peril that her
spirit is in and that is something that
I think is key to making these movies
effective when they do work or when it
comes to the scares I feel like some of
the jump scares are hit or miss in terms
of this horror movie value there are
some jump scary jump scares some of them
are saved by the fact that even the
stuff you kind of smirk at afterwards is
a flash of something relevant to the
story and in that way kind of enhanced
the more psychological the more human
elements of this it does have a good
sense of suspense I feel like there are
definitely times where it curled up not
necessarily as frightening as some of
the original ones but what I will say is
when people are in danger or being
aggressed upon by malevolent spirits
there are some moments like that they're
really intense and there are also some
jump scares that you got to give them
credit for ingenuity and like creativity
because while they didn't often catch me
off-guard when they would show up unless
they were completely out of nowhere they
did a good job of misdirecting my eyes
and making me finally so dizzy I'm like
I don't know when it's coming and from
where because I'm looking all over the
place and the music is different this
time
not as shrill as the previous movies
which I actually really appreciated
about the earlier movies when they first
came out especially
that sort of harsh raking string score
and all that but this one dials it back
it's still got some cool musical moments
but a lot of the scarier parts of the
movie are played in room tones silence
you're there with the characters and
then enhances the cinematography as well
and the supporting cast I thought was
also good I think the best of which was
Josh Stewart and Tessa Ferrer as Elise's
parents growing up I always enjoy when
Josh Stewart pops up in movies like this
especially cuz he seems like he takes
these seriously he's the star of the
collector films as well and I think he's
really good in those you've probably
seen him in some Chris Nolan movies and
Tessa Farah this is the first time I was
aware of having seen her but I thought
she did a great job as Elise's mother
even though those characters don't have
like the vast majority of screen time
they do leave an impression and I
thought both those actors brought
something to it Bruce Davison is in this
you know he's he's good he's not in a
huge role he's an important character
but not a giant character in terms of
writing her screen time Spencer locking
Kaitlyn Gerard from Zack stones gonna be
famous show up as Elise's nieces which
is cool this is a very family-oriented
movies about family this is gonna be the
fast and furious ghost franchise pretty
soon they're gonna find reasons to make
all of the demons good again oh yeah
it's right there the fantasy elements of
this movie - you're gonna have the
lipstick faced even for the first one
the woman in black from the first and
the second one then you're gonna have
the the man who couldn't breathe then
you're gonna have key face with the key
boney key fingers and the resident evil
nemesis mug you know that was a cool
element of this movie - I like that they
always have their boogeyman I thought
this character was neat and I actually
wanted to know more about certain
aspects of him and where he comes from
he's played by Javier Boatshed who's you
know the creature performer these days
is just an it now he's in this and the
further this time - the movie even
bothers to expand a little bit on the
further the mythology of the red doors
and the glimpses into the further you
get this time or of a different
aesthetic they're more prison like
because of her father is a prison
wardens there's a lot of that imagery in
there I feel like this movie bothered to
touch on everything so even when is
doing perhaps way too much at one time
everything it tries to do I feel like
was worth trying and I feel like they
brought dimension of some degree nuance
of some degree - most of the things they
tried to work with even if some are more
richly written than others because there
are some of those thinner or more
truncated moments that do kind
jostle the flow of the movie a little
bit it may cross a point for you I feel
like this movie's gonna hit everybody's
threshold differently where as too much
stuff happening for me it definitely
flirted with that line crossed it a few
times here and there even though I do
think this movie has a number of uneven
elements it could have used a little
more finesse perhaps a more focus it
certainly left an impression on me at
least as an insidious fan as a fan of
horror movies in general it's the fourth
of the Stallman of this franchise and I
appreciate that
even still they are trying to think of
thoughtful ways to expand this story it
doesn't no coalesce 100% of the time but
it tried so many things I thought were
cool it had a lot of surprises in it I
wasn't expecting it does seem like the
core Drive of this franchise is still
intact we didn't need a sequel to
insidious but it seems like every step
of the way they've thought what's the
most sensible way we can make a sequel
to this and while also keeping our
spirit intact I think for the most part
they've been pretty successful even if
you're only sticking around at this
point because you're a fan if you're
curious about it I'd say go check it out
if you're a fan I'd say definitely go
check it out there are elements of it
that I think are the strongest of this
franchise I mean Elise is as great as
she's ever been and she's something to
see in this movie I really liked that
story right now I guess off the top of
my head just having seen it yesterday I
probably go with like it's three and a
half for this movie I mean there are
some things I would have liked to seen
smoothed out it's not without its flaws
but I think there are definitely some
things they do here that are worth
appreciating that are good you need for
horror in general what do you guys think
have you seen the last key hit us up
with your thoughts in the comment
section and where would you like to see
Chapter five go if they take this
another step further haha into the
further I need to be beautiful anyhow
you can subscribe to the real rejects
hit that notification bed and get
notified every time a review or a video
is up download the star dust out follow
us first if you please we would very
much appreciate it and if you love us
you want to get involved with our little
patreon community patreon.com slash the
real reagent-x is a place to go for that
got lots of fun stuff special reactions
behind-the-scenes videos and pictures
yeah it's like a second youtube channel
where we can be us man we can be raw so
if that sounds fun to you come check it
out until then